fully factorize F dash X if f of X
equals and then you get this function
here now this function here is a product
like like we have seen in other
situations I'm going to put this x
squared to one side like I just
mentioned the constant coefficient can
be briefly ignored even though I don't I
don't get rid of it I just sort of put
it to one side and I'll come back to it
later and that leaves me with these two
pieces x squared and then e to the 2x so
just like with the question rule I'm
going to indicate this one as you and
this one as V so f dash is going to
equal to four there's that number that
constant coefficient just hanging out
the front and then my product rule looks
like V u dash Plus u v dash and I kind
of got ahead of myself I haven't
calculated u Dash and V dash yet but
maybe we can actually do this on the go
let's have a shot at it the four is
hanging out the front we haven't done
anything to it the V is e to the power
of 12x and if u is x squared then u dash
will be equal to 2x so there's my vu -
then I do + u V - and I repeat in the
other direction so u in this case is x
squared V - if I differentiate this I
deal with the inside than the outside so
the inside is 12 X its derivative will
be 12 there's the inside function and
then I deal with the outside function e
to the power something just becomes e to
the power of something there we go so
this is now differentiated I've used the
product rule but you'll notice that the
question doesn't let us get away with it
so easily
it says fully factorize and for what
it's worth most students did well with
the actual differentiation but and this
is not the last time it'll happen it was
actually algebra and the factorization
that really tripped up quite a few
people so let's have a go at this step
by step I'm going to simplify for
starters I've got a big mess here of
different terms so I'm going to write
for and in the brackets I've got 2x e to
the 12x and then I've got 12
oh there's 12 in the x-squared and then
again to the 12x now if you're very very
confident with your algebra you can kind
of do all this in one hit but I know a
lot of people look at that and they're
just kind of wince it's like ah it's
just algebra soup so we're gonna do is
one step at a time okay the first thing
I notice that's most obvious is this e
to the 12x it's kind of sticking out
like a sore thumb base I'm gonna
factorize that out since it's a common
factor for both terms so for e to the
12x once I factor that out I get left
with 2x plus 12x squared so I can do
another step of factorization in this
case why do we have a look at the
constants so there's a 2 here and a 12
here the highest common factor of both
of those is just 32 so if I take out two
there's already a 4 remember so this
will become 8 the end of the 12x is
still hanging out there the 2x will
divide it by 2 becomes X and then I get
left with 6x squared and finally I can
see there's an X here and then there's
two x's tucked away being multiplied
together there so if I take out a single
factor of X I end up with 8x either 12x
there's a 1 once I divide there and a
plus 6x now we're finished by the way
it's worth mentioning we're not just
asking you to do this for fun when we
differentiate something one of the
principal things that we do with it is
find things like stationary points
turning points and the easiest way to
find those is when the derivative is
equal to zero now it's much easier to
work out when this thing is equal to
zero because you can look at each of the
factors and say well when each one is
equal to zero that gives me a stationary
point as compared to a garbled mess like
this which is the complete derivative
but it's so messy it's really difficult
to actually work with it so that is the
reason why we focus on getting you to
become good at the practiced skill of
factorization all right the final
differential calculus question before we
talk into the integral calculus evaluate
F
- of Pi on 6 if f of X equals and then
you get this combination of
trigonometric functions and does say
leave your answer in exact form which
means when we're evaluating this we
can't just throw this into the
calculator we need to be very careful
with our exact values here right so if
we want F dash of PI on 6 what this
means is we want to take f dash we want
to get the derivative and then we want
to substitute PI on 6 into our value of
x so let's take that one step at a time
we'll do the derivative first if ever
the X is here then f dash X will become
well the sine X turns into cos of X and
cos a - X we have to use the chain rule
here so the inside derivative will be 2
and then the outside derivative will be
cos turns into negative sine
that's a a really easy thing to get
wrong because we've been spending so
much time mixing together
differentiation and integration and the
signs go backwards when you go forwards
and in Reverse with integration so be
extra cautious when you do
differentiation like this so there's my
derivative I will tidy this up just a
teeny a little bit it'll be cos of X
take away 2 sine 2x all right so there's
my F dash X now I need to substitute in
PI on 6 which that's in radians because
you know we're dealing with calculus
here so all of the derivative results
for trigonometry or Trina metric
functions they come from radians that's
why we can't just put degrees into there
but if you want to remember this is 30
degrees or it's equivalent to 30 degrees
so if we now substitute that angle into
the derivative we've got it's going to
be cos of Pi on 6 take away 2 sine -
lots of PI on 6 so before we actually
evaluate these trig functions I'll deal
with that - lots of PI on 6 that's going
to be 2 sine PI on 3 by the looks of
things okay now it's worth mentioning
this is where people fell down it wasn't
with the calculus it was with your exact
values and your use of these different
angles here so
of pylon six if you're struggling to
remember this you do have on your
reference sheet you do have let's find
it where is the spot hidden here we go
so here is this magical triangle which
helps you to work out all of your trig
ratios back in the days when I was a
student this didn't get given to us on
the reference sheet so this was the
first thing I drew on the top of every
exam because I was guaranteed that I
would need to use it now you can see
it's set up it's geared up four degrees
right now so let me go and redraw this
so that we can use it for radians so the
way I always remember it was you've got
a small angle up here so that must be
the PI on six the other angle is bigger
so it's PI on three the easiest ratio to
remember is sine of thirty degrees which
is sine of the PI on six it's equal to
1/2 which is opposite on hypotenuse one
over two that makes the third side root
3 so if you have a look at cos of Pi on
6 here causes adjacent on hypotenuse
there's the adjacent there's the
hypotenuse so I'm getting root 3 on 2
I'm now going to subtract two lots of
sine of PI on 3 and PI on 3 is over here
in this corner and if you have a think
about that it's actually going to be
because remember sine is opposite on
hypotenuse it'll still be root 3 on 2
it's just from the point of view of a
different angle so it's 2 lots of root 3
on 2 so root 3 on to take away - lots of
root 3 on 2 think about this for a
second X take away 2 X this is just
minus X and in this case my X is root 3
on 2 there you go you can see there's my
X there's my 2x so therefore without
having to worry about common
denominators or anything like that I can
immediately say it's from minus or
negative root 3 on 2 there's my solution
now these worth mentioning if you are
not confident with these results you can
actually work out using your calculator
how to do this let me show you how so
you use your calculator to evaluate
something like say I guess we'd go to
this line here cos of Pi on 6 minus 2
sine PI on 3 and perhaps you feel like I
am NOT confident with my exact values I
don't have time to draw
or interpret this other triangle which
is written in degrees not in radians
this is not always going to work but it
is a way that you can perhaps check and
answer and it's certainly better than
leaving your solution blank remember
into what we want is an exact value I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna first make sure
that I'm in radians which I don't think
I am so I'm gonna go shift setup and
press for 4 radians the first expression
I want to evaluate is cos of Pi on 6 so
let's go PI on 6 there and then I'm
going to subtract that from to sign and
I think we had pi/3 didn't we PI on 3
okay now if you hit equals here and you
get this result which is a bit of a
garbled mess and this will not cut it
because we've asked for an exact answer
so it's a decimal expansion we need
better than that but the first thing
I'll notice is that it's got a negative
sign on the front so I'm gonna write
down this is literally the way I'm
checking for myself a negative sign
before I write down my solution and now
what I do is this is a bit sneaky I want
to square the answer okay now the reason
I do that is because in the exact values
for trigonometric functions you see you
get square roots all the time you might
get rid 3 onto you like we just got you
might get 100 3 is another common value
because you get these square roots all
the time you get these SERDES
in order to see the fraction in a simple
way squaring will eliminate those Sert's
right so if I Square now this is the
answer squared I get 0.75 which you'll
recall is 3/4 now that's not the answer
that's the answer
squared so the real answer I want is the
square root of that what's the square
root of 3 over 4 well it's the square
root of 3 over 4 is the square root of 3
on the square root of 4 that's root 3 on
2 so you can see in your calculator even
though it can't directly hand you the
exact values at least not if it's Nessa
approved you can actually use this tiny
little hack to get to the answer or if
you're not sure to check the answer that
you got by doing it mentally so
hopefully that's a handy trick for you
to keep up your sleeve